hey this is presh talwalkar
this square abcd lies on a flat surface
alongside a b and a d are two flaps
each flap is in the shape of a regular
hexagon the vertices e and f are
adjacent to the vertex a
the top flap is rotated about side a b
at an angle of t
and the right flap is rotated about the
side ad at the same angle t
this is done until the points e
and f are coincident
in other words ae is equal to af
there are two parts to the question
first
what is the angle t
that each hexagonal flap was rotated
part two
what is the angle ae makes with the flat
surface
i thank bonik for the suggestion
a version of this problem appeared on
the jest exam in india
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
i found this problem extremely
challenging and interesting to solve
it took me a long time to work out a
solution
so here's one way to solve the problem
let's focus on the top hexagonal flap
without loss of generality suppose the
square abcd has a side length equal to
two
then each of the sides of the regular
hexagon has a side length equal to two
in particular ae is equal to two
now let's construct a right triangle a g
e
since we have a regular hexagon each
external angle is equal to 60 degrees
we thus have a special 30-60-90 right
triangle
since the hypotenuse length is equal to
2 the shorter leg will be half of that
which is equal to 1
and then eg will be equal to the longer
leg which is the square root of 3. now
let's set up a coordinate system where
the point a is zero zero zero
this hexagon will be rotated t degrees
upwards about the side a b
so now let's try to figure out the
coordinates of the point e
we have a which is the origin
one unit over we have g
we now have the point e which is
somewhere here
we know that eg has a length equal to
the square root of three
furthermore eg has been rotated
t degrees from the flat surface so this
angle is equal to t
we now have a right triangle so we can
solve for the lengths of the legs
one leg will be the square root of 3
times the cosine of t and the other leg
will be the square root of 3 times the
sine of t
so we can see that the point e has
coordinates 1
square root of 3 times the cosine of t
and its height is equal to the square
root of 3 times the sine of t
we can now do a similar calculation for
the other hexagonal flap
let's figure out the coordinates of
point f
this hexagonal flap is rotated the same
angle t about the side a d
by similar calculation we can see that
the coordinates of f are equal to the
square root of 3 times the cosine of t
comma 1 comma the square root of 3 times
the sine of t
now how can we solve for t
we want to rotate the two hexagonal
flaps such that e is equal to f
that means the first coordinates and the
second coordinates have to be equal
this implies that 1 is equal to the
square root of 3 times cosine t
this means cosine t is equal to 1
divided by the square root of 3 which
means t is equal to the inverse cosine
of 1 divided by the square root of 3
which is approximately equal to 54.7
degrees
and that's the answer to the first part
of the question
now let's consider a right triangle
where one of the acute angles is equal
to t
we need the cosine of t to be equal to
one divided by the square root of three
we can then solve for the length of the
other leg and this will be equal to the
square root of two thus we can solve
that sine t is equal to the square root
of two divided by the square root of 3.
we can then substitute
for sine t and cosine t in the
coordinates for e
we'll now just simplify this so that e
is equal to 1 comma one comma square
root of two
so now let's plot the points a and e
a is the origin and e is at one comma
one comma square root of two
we know the length of ae is equal to two
and we know that its height is equal to
the square root of two
we can thus solve for the length of the
other leg this will be equal to the
square root of two
we thus have an isosceles right triangle
because two of the legs are equal to the
square root of two
this means each of the acute angles is
equal to 45 degrees
thus ae makes an angle of 45 degrees
with the flat surface
and that's the answer to part two
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you